we met up with the cheeky boys who make
crazy challenges for over 10 million
followers on tick tock they brought 11
different items for us to play with and
each time we win a point our racket gets
more difficult two beginners with real
rackets vs two pros using random objects
and we brought some good ones we brought
some good ones so you better watch it to
the end zero zero i'm nervous i'm
nervous
uh-oh
oh got it got it what are you cheering
for
yeah it's for pongfinity
do we get a chance to try the surface no
no no
[Applause]
yeah you see it you see it you see it
you see it
[Music]
okay
okay guys what next this
[Music]
yeah
that's brutal
keep watching let's see move on to the
books
i don't know how fast this is
oh it's a fast off the whole
good thing is the more we lose the more
we win yeah okay
next one
yeah yeah just keep it back
i'm not gonna lie this means everything
yes got the serving
yeah it was nice it was good thank you
oh
looking pretty good
yes
[Applause]
i got greedy okay guys you're gonna
share an eye around not the first time
you're not sharing something that was
more about
[Applause]
pretty intimidating
[Music]
no it's really fun i forgot to tell you
yeah you should have shot it goes faster
the faster we go the harder it is
such a crazy one
that was incredible i can't believe you
returned that from you
that was very impressive very impressive
if you ask me guys are going to lose so
badly
we didn't ask you
what you don't know is we know finnish
ah it's over again
if you guys can iron my clothes for me
you can move on
[Applause]
we have to be aggressive
six
[Applause]
i wasn't because if i was i would have
hit it back
[Applause]
yes
i have to say it's looking better now
yeah can we get some advice what do you
think we need help
never play with those pedals
maybe he had to hit harder
harder do you think we have that in us
you hear that we gotta hit it as hard as
we can
it's a little harder
thank you very much thank you
yeah scared
see that
gave us a little bit of coaching and
it's easy go first
they're nervous now you can feel it look
at their faces come on
that was actually a really good
oh guys
he's pulled out the number one serves
see all we had to do was go get a little
bit of coaching
yeah
there was something special about that
coaching me and they're gonna go what
can we do all in and make it
by the way guys where did you get those
balls
what's going on this might actually go
like terribly wrong or something no no
our
that's cheating
so we weren't expecting that it's pretty
clever though gorgeous advice again that
was your suggestion unbelievable guys
guys
the guys thing ever
they didn't think of this when they were
choosing the items
[Applause]
oh sorry i'm sorry guys buddy
this is this is how we're gonna play the
game
get your spoons may have cheated our way
into the final points but maybe i have a
really bad feeling about the spoons yeah
it's not gonna work out good luck i'm
gonna be like down here somewhere
do they play with spoons in finland
that's better than the real racket
bring out the lamborghini
most expensive paddle in the world
the front mirror came off you broke our
car yeah it wouldn't be the first thing
they broke of ours okay match point
okay okay it's their serve now they're
switching techniques they don't know
what to do
oh
one more one more not even mad we got
like five shots on with a mini car 11
12.
one more it's a win in itself if we get
the serve on the table
[Applause]
well done congratulations to the winners
you get to keep the pongfinity racquets
thank you so much and to go with those
you get
a net what
so you just hook it up to any table any
table oh that's sick we're using are you
seeing this
huge thanks to the cheeky boys who
joined us remember to go and check out
their tick tock account they do
hilarious stuff subscribe to them though
for real they gotta win something
thank you for the audience
thank you so much
[Applause]